hmm angel what is it
it's just I'm going over your file here
and there seems to be something missing
it I mean what what what are your powers
again
I fly yeah I know you fly but what else
that's it you fail you're fired
my bones are hollow that enables me to
soar great distance I should have let
you go I love to hear your retort hey
you have any idea how many of the extra
in fly and do something else incredible
you just fly and it's not even like an
internal power like something you focus
it you literally have giant wings bird
flapping your wings as hard as you can
to lift your stupid abs in the air your
angel wings I'm looking right at them
those are bird wings just huge in on a
man I'm surprised you haven't choked on
one of those plastic ring thingies maybe
if I peck at this huh huh Greenpeace
help but you need me I do not need a
bird bird but I do have a question you
prefer your seed loose or in a bell
shape on a bird or is it a pine cone
with with peanut butter and then you
stick the seed to it I'm not a bird bold
words man with huge bird wings and
hollow bones are you bird
Hey look you're giving a bird the bird I
got what are you doing
one small favor bird when you get your
worthless ass out of my office would you
resist the urge to [ __ ] on my car
I just hate it when your people [ __ ] on
my car
oh wait let me fire you in your native
tongue chip chip chip bird hey maybe you
don't want seed but perhaps I could
interest you in some pasta salad no I
don't know what if I regurgitate it for
you you know bird style what here bird
here this will help you fly bird hey
angel put on a shirt this is a school
for gifted youngsters not a Victoria's
Secret model runway you bird bird can
miss that bird